Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today we'll be discussing the question
how similar our metropolitan French and
Quebec French or Quebecois.
In other words,
how similar is the French spoken in
France to the French spoken in Quebec.
French is one of the world's major
languages and it's spoken in dozens of
different countries and everywhere that
it's spoken,
the standard variety or the formal
variety that's learned at school and
used in the media is essentially the
same as metropolitan French based on the
Parisian variety of French in informal
speech.
However,
there is some variation with local
differences in accents and vocabulary.
There's one major variety of French that
is particularly distinct from
Metropolitan French,
and that is the French chef Quebec,
a culturally distinct French speaking
province in Canada.
French speakers from France often say
that they have trouble understanding the
French spoken in Quebec.
I should point out that the formal
variety of French Houston,
Quebec is virtually identical to
metropolitan French.
The differences lie in the informal
varieties of Quebec and an informal
speech.
There can be a considerable amount of
difference,
but why is Quebec French distinct from
Metropolitan French?
The reason lies in the settlement of new
France and the later isolation of Quebec
from France.
New France was an area in North America
that was colonized by France before the
creation of Canada and the United
States,
the first settlers in new France.
We're not mainly from the Paris area,
but from regions like Normandy and
Brittany were regional sister.
Languages of French lung doyle were
spoken rather than French itself,
but since French settlers were
outnumbered by English settlers,
the King of France,
King Louis the 14th sent female settlers
mainly from the Paris area to help
bolster their numbers through marriage
and childbirth.
Since these women were mainly from the
Paris area,
they brought with them their Parisian
variety of French,
which contributed to the decline of the
regional languages and the adoption of
French among the settler population.
And of course the interaction between
speakers of different regional languages
encouraged the use of French as a Lingua
Franca.
As a result.
The language that developed in new
France was similar to the language
spoken by the king and the aristocracy,
but was also influenced by the regional
languages of the settlers.
The French language became adopted
throughout the various regions of
France.
Later after the French Revolution of the
late 18th century,
the variety of French that became the
new widespread standard language was not
the French of the king and the
aristocracy,
but rather the French of the bourgeois
class who led the revolution prior to
the French Revolution.
New France had already been conquered by
the British in 1760 and it's elite had
returned to France.
The British soon decided to allow the
French speaking population in what is
now Quebec to continue using their
language as a way to prevent them from
joining the American revolution against
the British,
which was taking place to the south.
Come back,
therefore remained under British rule,
but was isolated from France.
The French language in Quebec began
developing in its own direction.
While the French spoken in France
developed in its own direction.
The vocabulary.
The vocabulary of Quebec French differs
from that of Metropolitan French in
several ways.
First,
the two varieties of French have taken
in loan words from English during
different time periods.
The French of Quebec was infused with
English vocabulary during the period
from 1850 to 1960 for example,
the word for job in Quebec,
French there is in metropolitan French
in Quebec,
French weird and Metropolitan French
visa.
In Quebec,
French there's chum meaning a male
friend or a boyfriend and in
metropolitan French that would be me or
the coupon in Quebec,
French,
there's fun in metropolitan French,
it's a museum.
Fun also appears in the phrase,
which is a direct translation of the
English expression to have fun.
In Metropolitan French,
it would be send Musey expressions like
this are called calcs or lone
translations.
Another example is this is translated
from English that makes sense.
In metropolitan friendship would be sad.
You songs and then Quebec French people
say to me,
you're welcome,
but in metropolitan French they would
say,
do the young.
The old venue means welcome in all
varieties of French,
but not your welcome in response to
thank you.
Note that these are informal Quebecois
words,
which are not considered proper and
formal Quebec French,
which mirrors the standards of
Metropolitan French.
Since 1960 there have been French
language protection laws in Quebec and
the general distaste towards English
systems.
Metropolitan French,
on the other hand,
doesn't have the same protective
attitude,
and in recent decades has been more
influenced by English,
so it contains recent English loan words
that are not used in Quebec.
For example,
in metropolitan French,
they say email,
but in Quebec,
French they say,
all right,
cool.
In Metropolitan French,
there's fun.
In Quebec they say stop signs in France,
say,
stop.
This is not really a part of the French
language.
It's just an international used street
sign.
But in Quebec,
the sign say another aspect of
vocabulary that differs is that there
are some words or expressions in Quebec,
French that seem older or more
traditional to speakers of metropolitan
French.
The Quebecois word for shoes is in
metropolitan French.
It's detial sue the Quebecois word for
car or Shell.
In France,
it's [inaudible].
Shar means tank as in tank of war.
Another example is the way to say I miss
you in Quebec,
it's [inaudible] in France.
That would sound rather old fashion and
the way people would usually say it is
[inaudible].
The French of Quebec also contains
numerous slang expressions and swear
words that are taken from the Catholic
religion.
Perhaps the most famous where word of
Quebec is.
Others include car lists,
meaning chalice,
a c meaning host or communion bread.
These words are only offensive and
Quebec and nowhere else in the
Francophone world as far as I know,
and the French of Quebec has also just
developed some of its own vocabulary and
expressions.
For example,
to go shopping in Quebec,
friendships in metropolitan French,
it's cld,
Kooks Clg,
shipping grammar written French in
Quebec is grammatically identical to
metropolitan French,
but an informal speech you might hear
some differences in grammar too is used
after verbs as a yes or no question
marker that's in blown.
This means,
do you have a girlfriend in metropolitan
French [inaudible]?
[inaudible].
Notice here that is being used as a yes
or no question marker and not as a
pronoun.
Also notice the Quebecois word for
girlfriend bloomed.
This means is it ready in metropolitan
French.
That would be sip.
Sam Is cusip saying here,
notice that the subject is third person.
To be clear too is nothing but a
question marker here.
It's not the second person Pronoun too.
It's also used for emphasis or
exclamation.
See,
that's so shocking.
Seats.
You should come next.
In Quebec,
French cook is used as the relative
pronoun more often than in metropolitan
French.
Just Shush.
I leave Casey business.
This means I'm looking for the book that
I need in metropolitan French.
This would be [inaudible] and in a
sentence with an embedded question.
In Metropolitan French you use a
relative pronoun,
but in Quebec French the interrogative
pronoun is used.
Should I say this means I do what I want
in metropolitan French [inaudible] next
in Quebec French.
The explicit subject of a sentence is
often said as a tag with a pronoun as
the subject in the main clause.
For example,
mall bus.
This means my boss makes me so angry.
Notice how the subject,
my boss is set aside at the beginning
separate from the main clause and then
the Pronoun e which is a contraction of
eel appears in the main clause in
metropolitan French.
This would be in Quebec,
French pla towards mound.
This means his plan is to travel around
the world.
In metropolitan French it would be so
pushy ewg.
This type of tag is also used in
metropolitan French but as much more
common in Quebec,
French.
Next there are some differences in
imperative forms in Quebec French.
This means tell me or tell it to me.
In Metropolitan French denim you can see
that the object Pronoun La is positioned
differently and now the negative form in
metropolitan French in the deeper you
can see that in the negative,
the syntax is quite different.
In Metropolitan French,
the object Pronoun Ma is used instead of
the French emphatic Pronoun Wa often
pronounced where in Quebec,
and it comes before the verb as does the
object Pronoun Look in Quebec,
French,
they come after the verb as they do in
the affirmative accent.
Probably the biggest difference between
the French of Quebec and Metropolitan
France simply lies in accent without
previous exposure to the French spoken
in Quebec.
French speakers from Europe typically
have trouble understanding it,
and this differs depending on the
socioeconomic background and the region
of the speaker.
The consonants are not so different for
the most part,
but there are some differences in
Quebec,
French before the vowels e and Oo,
the consonants to enter become enza gg.
Whereas in metropolitan French it's
pronounced two d.
There are several different rotate
sounds used throughout Quebec,
including trill sounds as opposed to the
Uvula fricative of Metropolitan French.
However,
this is also true in France where some
regional accents have trills rather than
fricatives and in Quebec in formal
speech and in many areas,
the uvular fricative is also used.
So the situation in Quebec and Francis
similar except that in France,
the shift towards the uvular fricative
is more advanced vowels.
One difference is that nasal vowels are
quite different.
In Quebec,
French,
there's CAF,
and in metropolitan French there's
another difference is that in Quebec,
French,
long vowels and nasal vowels become
diphthongs in open syllables.
So in Quebec,
French we have fights,
but in metropolitan French there's sit
in Quebec,
French,
we have pi in metropolitan French,
it's damn related to that.
Quebec French retain some long vowels
from older French that have become short
in metropolitan French.
For example,
in metropolitan French,
these two words sound the same mate
mate,
but in Quebec,
French,
they don't.
My Net,
these are just a couple of examples,
but there are numerous distinctions like
these intervals.
Some words also become contracted in
Quebec,
French,
for example,
sue meaning on followed by a definite
article,
gets contracted sill say,
now let's look at a few sentences to
compare.
Here's the sentence,
meaning I fell in love with her because
she's beautiful in Quebec.
French.
She tell him down that I called Kenny
van and in metropolitan French she vm
Udin Pascali Bill.
Here we can see a quebecois expression
Tome Bay on the Moon [inaudible],
which is a calc of the English
expression fall in love with,
and here we see two different phrases,
meaning because I called Tsca is an
older phrase,
which is obsolete and metropolitan
French,
but it's still used in Quebec.
Another pair of sentences.
This time they mean I want to go out
with my friends on the weekend
in Quebec,
French off to Hong Gang,
often salmon
and in metropolitan French [inaudible]
weekend in the Quebec French sentence we
see on gun,
which means with a group of friends or
colleagues.
This phrase is strictly a Quebecois
phrase,
so when Metropolitan French you'd say
something like,
evict me.
Awesome.
Next we see the phrase of fantasy man,
which means on the weekend in
metropolitan French,
the usual term is the weekend or in this
context,
so weekend.
This is an [inaudible] that has not
entered Quebec French due to its
language protection efforts in
metropolitan French.
Someone might say,
fend to some man,
but to refer to the end of the workweek
like Thursday,
Friday before the weekend.
Now let's look at one last pair of
sentences.
This time they mean I'm going to park
the car here and ride my bike
in Quebec,
French.
Should we be back?
It'll show you see your motives
and Metropolitan French choosy guide of
which you receive a porn movie loo.
Here we see a uniquely Quebecois phrase
park in the Shah with the verb that
comes from the English word park and
again we see the word Sha meaning car
and notice that the words for bicycle
are different in Quebec,
the common word is BC clit.
This word isn't a lone word from
English.
In fact,
it appeared in French before the word
bicycle appeared in English.
It's a standard French word,
but is generally considered old
fashioned to speakers of metropolitan
French who mainly use the word veilleux.
As we've seen,
the French of Quebec has a number of
different features that distinguish it
from metropolitan French,
but it seems to me that people sometimes
exaggerate these differences.
There are significant differences in
accent,
but that seems like something that would
cease to be much of a problem with
significant exposure to it.
In terms of vocabulary,
Quebec has its own informal expressions
and slang,
but so do other French speaking areas
including Paris in terms of grammar,
there are some little things here and
there but nothing too shocking.
And of course formal French in Quebec is
very close to formal French in France,
albeit with a different accent.
The question of the day for native
speakers of French from Quebec,
from your point of view,
how different is your variety of French
from the French spoken in Europe and for
native speakers of French from Europe?
How well can you understand the French
spoken in Quebec and for learners of
French,
assuming that you're learning
metropolitan French,
what do you think of the French spoken
in Quebec?
Is it hard to make sense of?
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter and instagram and once again
thank you to all of my patrion
supporters,
especially my top tier or Patrion
these wonderful people right here on the
screen.
Many thanks to them and to everyone.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.